an exciting ibm and a t collaboration
around 5g and edge a new partnership
with clearblade
and the introduction of code risk
analyzer all
on this episode of ibm cloud now what's
up y'all my name is ian and i am back
to bring you the latest and greatest
news and announcements from ibm cloud
last week ibm announced new work with at
t
to help enterprise clients capture the
5g opportunity
with secure open hybrid cloud
capabilities
the solution is putting a firm stake in
the ground around
ibm's hybrid cloud strategy because at t
is leveraging ibm cloud satellite
which is our secure and open hybrid
cloud platform built on red hat
openshift
the collaboration is designed to make it
easier for clients to utilize the
opportunities around 5g
in any environment in many ways
the telco industry has been right at the
forefront of keeping people connected
and bringing disruptive innovation along
the way two of the major driving factors
behind this rapid pace of transformation
are hybrid cloud and 5g and edge which
are expected to be a 667 billion dollar
business opportunity
by 2026 this is why ibm and at t
have extended their strategic
partnership to leverage ibm cloud
satellite
for at t's 5g and edge offerings
to learn more about this exciting
collaboration check out the full details
i've got linked in the description of
this video
next up i've got another exciting
partnership for ibm this one with
clearblade which is an edge computing
software company
this partnership focuses on offering
autonomous edge computing
and iot solutions the combination of
ibm edge application manager and
clearblade's edge platform
will benefit enterprise customers who
are building out end-to-end
edge computing solutions for
manufacturing transportation
healthcare and other industries through
working with clearblade
we aim to help enterprises rapidly
deploy process
store and analyze data at the edge
unlocking their full potential
to digitally transform by embracing
automation
and acting on insights closer to where
their data is created
clients will be better able to mobilize
their container workloads
to run at the most optimal edge
locations
to learn more about this opportunity and
the power of edge computing
click the link i've included below okay
to wrap things up today i've got good
news for all my developer friends out
there
reducing the risk of incorporating
vulnerabilities into your code
is critical to successful development
and that's why we're proud to announce
code risk analyzer a new feature of ibm
cloud continuous delivery
code risk analyzer enables developers
like you to quickly
assess and remediate security and legal
risks that are potentially introduced
into your source code
and it provides feedback directly into
your git artifacts
it's provided as a set of tecton tasks
which can be easily incorporated
into your delivery pipelines code risk
analyzer provides capabilities like
vulnerability scans deployment analysis
and a bill of materials that accounts
for all dependencies
and their sources for your application
to get started with this great new
feature make sure you see the full post
linked below thanks so much for joining
me today for this episode of ibm cloud
now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now